welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham aziz and on
this week's episode i was joined by
glenn tovey who for the last five years
have been building his recruitment
career with a company called 94 group he
started the company as the first
employee and from then he's being able
to go on this amazing journey where he's
now leading 30 people strong he's been
involved in launching several different
brands and we broke down how he builds
new markets how he approaches head
hunting and how he gets the best out of
young people to progress and achieve
their goals enjoy the episode
glenn welcome to the podcast thanks for
having me
looking forward to this i think i
mentioned to you when
we were preparing for this and going
through it that i've had so many people
recently sort of say to me that they'd
love for me to sit down with people that
are sort of in the trenches right now
building their career i've sat down with
a lot of founders and entrepreneurs but
i think a lot of people want to be able
to learn from people like yourself and
listen to someone like yourself because
you've gone on this journey in the last
sort of five years where obviously when
you sit down with recruitment companies
they'll sort of point at people like you
and go look if you start here today you
could potentially if you work hard and
progress your career you could sort of
achieve some of the things that glenn
our director now um has achieved right
so i'm really excited to unpack this
we're going to talk about everything
from leadership growing teams
the struggles the hardships um but where
we always like to start um and i think
obviously as you've gone on this sort of
leadership journey you've fought long
and hard about this but i'd love to hear
your take on the characteristics and
traits that you believe make up a
successful recruiter in today's market
yeah absolutely so you know thanks for
having me on um i guess to go over what
i think a good recruiter looks like in
today's market space is
i think there's got to be a reason on
why someone wants to move into
recruitment to start with i think
individuals that are moving into the
sector uh have to be motivated and
there's got to be a background reason on
why they're motivated so for me you know
when i'm interviewing people i want to
understand more about
their background
why is it they want to go into the
sector
for me i wanted to work in an
environment where i was measured on how
hard i was working rather than just
being
a number within an organization like i
wanted to be in a position where if the
harder i work the more money i can make
and i feel like in recruitment as an
environment is the perfect it's the
perfect place to be able to do that how
would you describe glenn before
recruitment then because i think a lot
of people fall into recruitment it can
typically be an accident you said that
you wanted to be rewarded for your hard
work yeah how who would you how would
you describe glenn before recruitment
yeah so um before recruitment i was at
university um i spent a year at
university um
made a decision that to be honest
university wasn't right for me um i was
studying nutritional science at the time
oh wow really really enjoyed the course
but didn't actually see how i could make
a career out of being in being a
nutritional scientist so basically i
made the decision that uh i wanted to
move into a career where i could
essentially grow my commercial skill set
and move into more of a commercial focus
career
so i moved into a company called
dexter's which is an estate agency yeah
i spent about six months in that
business
that business went through the majority
of the growth that they already wanted
to go through well over 52 offices in
london like they went through that
growth and i joined at the entry level
it that taught me
how i can develop a commercial skill
sets what it's like to be in a sales
environment what it's like to be at the
bottom actually really work hard and how
to get to the top but for me
although sales is a environment where
the harder you work the quicker you
progress i feel like in that environment
they already had gone through the level
of growth they wanted to and i probably
caught that business three years too
late right um
so i made the decision that uh i wanted
to move into the recruitment sector uh
and i wanted to move into 94 which which
i viewed as a high growth business uh so
then uh that should have more of an
impact
phil probably may be more valuable and
yeah have more impact on the business so
just quickly on that a lot a lot of
graduates listen to this a lot of young
people listen to this how how hard was
it to look at yourself in the mirror and
go i don't want to be in at uni anymore
because that's that's hard that's a hard
decision right yeah like it's a it's a
big decision to make um i made the
decision myself um i did speak to my
family to friends they're supportive
they're they're very supportive uh like
the end of the day it was my decision
that i made i'm quite headstrong in the
decisions that i make um it was a
measured decision like i thought about
uh staying at university
creating that debt which everyone goes
through when going to university and
then thinking
can i get into a role where i can
generate personal wealth for myself
early on i was 19 at the time uh i was
going on 20 um
yeah and for me you know 19 years old
the easy option would have been to stay
at university yeah study knuckle down
get my degree uh get my two one uh
like it seems like most most of the
graduates have achieved and and then and
then move into the sector or a sales
sales role three years later and for me
that's sort of three years wasted in my
opinion so i made the decision
at 19 to to pack a bag uh and move to
move to london no no fair play because
i'm obviously there's so much there's
you put pressure on yourself yeah you've
got pressures from other people's
opinions and all that so i i really
respect that so i just wanted to just
hear your take on it because i know
that's just so difficult right yeah um
so let's just frame this up then so like
this obviously describe today sort of
where 94 is and your involvement and
then we'll sort of work back from that
so she was saying earlier that obviously
you're responsible mainly for the 94
tech team but you're a director and
oversee the different brands within 94
yeah um and you currently have was it 30
people
in the 94 tech team that you're
responsible for um
so let's work back from here because
obviously
it's been a journey to get up to that
point yeah so let's just maybe just
start
because it's typically
the hardest year of recruitment the
first year yeah um obviously joined uh
94. what did little what did it look
like when you joined was it just ed
who's obviously the founder was it just
you as the first hire yeah so i was the
first hire in the business um
for me that was really awesome because
i've got the exposure to work with ed um
but when i first joined 94 i bought into
the vision which was to be a multi a
multi-brand agency
covering
multiple locations
which was a purely organic platform
which which really engaged me you know
working on an organic platform where
you've got direct exposure to an
individual that's already successfully
scaled and sold recruitment agencies
was a bit of a no-brainer for me and
where i was at dexter's um
yeah i was quite a few levels off
getting that level of exposure to the
person at the top so um was in a box
room
me and ed were in a box room and
we started building
what was uh 94 groups so our first brand
was 94 tax okay
so 94 tax is a specialist technology
head hunting firm uh that focuses on
placing candidates into the professional
services sector yeah
now
that business was pretty much uh grown
from the ground up um i think 94 was
started a few months prior just by ed
before i joined
and sitting in that box room you know we
were trying to work out how to win
clients how to build a candidate
database and i was sat there going well
how do i actually do recruitment
so um putting all of that together it
was a lot of exposure quite early doors
and yeah they always say
throw yourself in the deep end and see
what happens uh i feel like i've
definitely done that um
now for me um building that candidate
database building that client database
trying to actually work out and
commercially understand how you make
revenue in a market space
whilst trying to work out what
recruitment is full stop was was quite
challenging
um we only had a couple clients at the
time um
my first deal actually in the business
was inside two weeks of joining really
um
yep which was a very proud moment for me
and that was into a new client which i
won which uh i'm super super passionate
about so talk me through that just
really quickly because people
people will be listening going
like you're in it's just you and ed you
haven't done recruitment before
you obviously got terms of a client yeah
and you
did a placement yeah two weeks yeah what
like how so um for us
the where the platform was it was a
completely underdeveloped platform there
was pretty much zero clients uh and zero
candidates but we wanted to build that
platform from the ground up
so
we had
business development takes techniques
that i was taught and a significant
amount of training and development that
was put into me so i got external
training through our external trainer
which still runs the external training
today called james bass
and then i also got the internal
training from ed
and that was really focused on business
development and scaling out clients so
you know
not one business development technique
actually works to win a client in my
opinion like you've got to be pretty
creative there so you know we were
specking we were cv stripping we're back
filling and and for me i picked a market
i picked a a location i picked a a
market within tax which was plating
private client tax professionals
into
a purposely picked a market outside of
london which was less saturated where i
saw there was other competitor
organizations there and business
develops into that competitor
organization
and expect into them uh
negotiated that terms of business uh and
led with that candidate and placed that
candidate
nice yeah how uh
a common challenge i don't know if you
see this in the young people that you uh
employ now but how did you looking back
where did the confidence come from
you're someone that would potentially be
perceived as a failed uni student yeah
that then worked in a company for
obviously a short period then you're in
recruitment and you're speaking to tax
professionals that you could easily look
at and go
like who am i to speak to these people
who am i to be competent and confident
enough to talk to them about the job
opportunities and like get lost in like
not having enough credibility at that
point to be worthy of like speaking to
them and those things like how how did
you looking back like where that
confidence come from to do those things
you know because that can be a real
challenge for people yeah so for me
the way i look at it is
you i i will rank the three different
types of stakeholders that i'm engaging
with okay including myself which is the
consultant the candidate and the clients
and i'm not going to go over where i
where i rank them
i purposely do put myself at the top of
that list because
the transaction with the candidate and
the transaction the client doesn't
happen without me and they're coming out
to a third-party agency because they
can't fill that role which is what i
think every recruitment firm that's
there in the market space today and if
you're a month in or if you're six
months in you you've got to have that
appreciation that
they need you that's how you have to
view it yeah exactly and confidence is
everything um
if you can't sound confident you're not
going to sound credible and if you're
not credible they're not going to buy
into you
and to get bought buy-in from a tax
professional for me
i think that's great but for me that's
it's not to be honest that the most
engaging thing for me okay um
it's
i view myself at peer level with every
single person i'm engaging with um and i
joined the business when i was you know
just turned 20 years old i was i was
three months into my 20th birthday um
and that was super super engaging for me
um and i was i was quite confident i was
quite cocky quite early on which uh ed
worked with me to channel
and it moved me into a position where i
started to work on my own professional
maturity and that then linked very
closely into personal maturity and i
think
to go on a journey where you then scale
up and then
hire only organic talents
you know i'm still working on with
talent at the moment which we're on
boarded which some of them are 19 years
old that are working through this
business today younger than i was and it
resonates with me that if i've done it
other people can do it and professional
maturity is is something that you learn
and you've got to have patience and i
went through the point of having the
patience myself in that environment so
um
to your point i i don't think um
i don't think when you join a business
and you're sat there speaking to a tax
professional it's necessarily a i'm so
lucky to speak with you it's more of a
you're speaking to me because the the
level of intelligence that i can give
you on the market dynamic even by being
in the market a week is i know the
salaries of all of the large competitor
firms which which they won't have access
to which immediately they're gaining
value by engaging with me so
so hopefully that sort of answers your
question yeah yeah yeah yeah so
and i think that's sometimes what people
struggle with is like you said
making sure that as a consultant you
view the value that you bring and i
think sometimes you can miss that or
like lose sight of that when you sort of
see early on and you like you just said
you just feel lucky that they're
speaking to you sort of things so that's
really interesting that you share that
so
let's unpack some of this progression
then right so because over the last sort
of five years you've progressed all the
way from that point you're talking about
now to becoming a director so talk to me
a bit about because it's a real
challenging period for um people like
when did you start then managing people
you said obviously quite corky earlier
and you had to develop that professional
maturity when did you then actually
start actually having people underneath
you that you was then responsible for
like what was the timeline until your
sort of first hire and you going on that
management leadership journey yeah
absolutely so um
for me i started uh obviously started in
august of uh not august of 17. yeah um
like for me the first year was basically
developing and scaling out what was our
tax business yeah with
no head count no leadership working on
my capability to be able to build
consult uh and actually build
credibility in the market
myself and ed basically sat down and set
what was a
a year-long objective
quite early on to me joining um around
revenue produced in a 12-month period
but also new client acquisition to
ensure that we've got a scaled business
in place before i then go across and and
launch what is 94 tech today so
what does it sorry it's a button but
what because i think this would be
useful for people what were what was
your revenue metrics are you aiming for
and what was your client sort of um
commitment and i don't know sign terms
with um customers goals because i think
that is interesting because i think
they're the sort of metrics that people
look at to then go right we're ready to
hire someone yeah would you mind sharing
those i think that'd be really useful
for people yeah so it's 200 000 pounds
inside your first 12 months
of uh employment which is quite a punchy
target yeah you know what about
client-wise how many clients did you
want to sort of have on your books then
go right if we get someone in there's
gonna they're gonna have stuff to work
on sort of immediately yeah so the
accountancy
the tax the tax market you you want to
look at you you want to have a blend of
clients which aren't just your top 10
accounting firms where there's loads and
loads of barrier to entry you're on
boarding a big forward is not the
easiest thing to to do sure there's
loads of process there's there's rpos in
place you we wanted to have a blend of
clients across uh the uk which wasn't
just sat in london that wasn't just a
big four so
for me it was being able to develop
not just our personal tax capability but
other areas within tax so that we can
successfully build out markets across
every tax discipline where we can then
cross fertilise all them clients in so
an accounting firm will need to hire a
personal tax professional a corporate
tax professional an employment tax
professional and then we started
thinking about that market and how you
break that down and and you can have a
consultant in every single tax
discipline that you work in so it was
basically to build a client base that
could sustain uh a long-term uh platform
to then scale up and grow and grow that
tax business um
i then moved across in august of 18 to
then launch 94 tech so um why'd you do
that
tax was already
an idea that was already in the business
before joining me and ed were always
like let's let's let's do a market which
is high growth and highly scalable
because like we're organic but we've got
clear ambition to significantly grow so
for me i wanted to work in a market
space which i could scale up not just
around tax disciplines but around
the wider market space which is you know
how many areas of technology is there
how many tech agencies are there and how
can you stand out from the crowd and for
me
i wanted to i wanted to work in a market
space where i could i could see super
scalability um
so i remember me and ed were actually
out for uh drinks we're at a rooftop bar
and he said right you've met these
metrics we're going to kick this off in
a month's time let's prep up and uh we
were probably a few drinks and i said no
no let let's start on monday
let's let's build a technology agency on
monday so um
me being me uh i made the decision that
it's gonna happen on monday okay uh we
started at that on monday and and for me
that's probably my my hardest time in
recruitment which was august through to
december of 18. really
yeah so difficult
well
we had no clients we didn't we firstly
we had to develop a candidate in a
client pool but before we can do that we
needed to understand what was the market
what was the location what was the spec
what was the niche what was the skill
sets and figuring that out does take a
period of time to understand like what's
hot and what's not and when you start
looking at competitor analysis you start
looking at uh other organizations how
they're how they're uh how they're
set up
what's the size of the candidate pool
what's the size of that client pool um
what's the different ways of business
developing um for me the big challenge
was
the way that you'd bd in
a tax accounting f
accountancy firm is super different to
the way that you bd in a
tech market yeah it's so different and
that was a really harsh wake-up call
because in attacks
what didn't work
uh that may be worked in the tax spec
spending yeah you could always lead with
a candidate and
i think in the markets i've worked in
quite a few markets i've worked in
multiple locations now in tax in tech
obviously seeing how the overall
business is run
and different markets require different
bd techniques and and speccing and
leading with a candidate just doesn't
work and you've got your candidate-led
market you've got your client-led market
and for me when i when i look at that i
would say tech is very client-led okay
where if you've got the client on
there's loads of candidates and all we
do is head hunt we don't use job boards
we're a pure market mapping and head
hunting firm so if we train our people
well enough and we've got the client on
there's no
there's no uh barrier to them producing
revenue apart from themselves yeah and
and for me that was that was quite
exciting because um in the tax market it
was
if you've got the candidate
uh you're always going to make it
indoors yeah exactly but imagine having
the candidate in tech and you're b d
with this candidate and they're going
not responding to you and you're like
what's going on here and it takes a
period of time to adapt to that because
i had such such a successful first year
and that was quite uh a hard period of
recruitment for me and i'd say that's my
hardest time because of building what
was a technology agency from scratch
with
investment and support but the direction
of travel was down to myself and how
hard i worked and
trying to work out how to bd trying to
work out what the different markets are
why it's not easy talk to him about talk
to me about your worst day than in that
period
my worst day um three offers on the
board uh our worst week
three offers on the board three crosses
um i lost sight on how to close
because i was so hungry and i was so
fixated on making that revenue
and
i had it in my head
it's on the ball it's going to close on
the board it's going to close and
because it because i it was a few months
before i'd made revenue and it was a
down period for me
i got complacent um and complacency
really affects i think a modern day
recruiter if you're complacent
especially at the entry level it's going
to catch you out and i was super super
complacent
first one i closed on money
second one i closed on money and the
third one i closed on money and i didn't
really know my candidates very well and
uh i lost 60k wow
so for me how did you how did you do it
that week
how did you dust that off how did like
because that's tough for a lot of people
yes i link it back to where i started
uh i joined recruitment i'm 20 years old
i'm trying to work out what weighs up
and i'm linking that back to
where i started and thinking
i'm bloody lucky to be in the position
i'm in i've got loads and loads of
investment and support i've got backing
by
a fantastic
founder of our business which i've got a
lot of time and respect for and he
wrapped around me he supported me he
invested into me uh he he stayed clear
on what that end goal was and i've never
lost sight of that end goal
i've also got a very very supportive
girlfriend um
so she was actually my last tax
placement which i think was
pretty comical um
and that helped
yeah yeah absolutely they say in
recruitment of three c's
i'm one off uh sorry i've only done one
uh just to confirm not done no came
around here and so it's a tough week so
like okay so let's unpack this a bit
because i think this would be really
useful and then we'll go into the
leadership staff
so
obviously so you had that got complacent
working out how what how sort of
business development worked
in the technology market yeah
so talk me talk me through like what did
you sort of keep a close
eye on or what would you keep in top of
mind when you was on that period to
really make you feel like right i'm on
the right track here i'm doing the right
things because i think
it can be really it can really um be
non-forgiving and thank thankless tata
recruitment isn't it where like if for
three months you're doing all these
things and you then get to the point of
having free deals and then they drop out
you're like [ __ ] now i'm back to
square one yeah so like what what would
you keep an eye on that then made you
feel like right i'm gonna do more of
that or right that's happened so now i'm
gonna focus on that so what were some of
the things that you really were keeping
top of mind that helped you understand
what you need to be doing more of and
what you need to be doing less of
yeah like specking didn't work and i
spent a good period of time doing that
and like that why didn't it work so
there was literally like they just they
just weren't coming back to you there's
no bites no attraction at all no no no
not at all and
that's pretty challenging when you're
specking out you're specking out a
hundred times a day five days a week
you're following up on that as well
you're working bloody hard to build that
business and you're getting a response
um
for me for me that that that was super
super challenging um what i needed to do
to basically stay on track for me it was
you've gotta you've got to be able to
pivot you've got to be able to change
your approach and you've got to be able
to look in the mirror quite quickly and
go look that's not working you've got to
be able to change and for me it was
layering in more business development
techniques to ensure that we had client
diversification if we've got the client
i know we can make the revenue because
head hunting is
is is what i've been taught is what i've
been doing from day one so if you had
like good quality brands and businesses
to talk to people about is confident
that you then have yeah okay yeah and
client diversification is important i
think as long as you've got the client
the client piece in place and you've got
building that client group
you should always be able to plastic so
what tactics started to work and then
what other things did you bake in and
that started to get traction what worked
yeah so
we've done a lot of reference calling
which i think is really really good like
i think you can build a market
through a candidate
without uh having to even look at the
clients but the clients will come so the
candidate was
uh
building and developing a candidate
database and asking them for two
professional references
every single time that you're speaking
to them and talk me through this call
because it like this we haven't spoken
about this before yeah
tommy so you get two professional
references yeah what are you then
calling these people and saying
well i think firstly like the
professional referencing is is a really
really neat way
to uh speak to
prospective hiring managers that aren't
already giving you the first time so if
the hiring manager is not going to speak
to you about hiring new talent because
they've got a supplier list in place or
because they can do it through their
internal capability you've got to find a
new way to actually get in touch with
that hiring manager so reference calling
is a way of you know you've got their
mobile number yeah
you've got their contact you're
referencing a candidate they've
previously employed it's a really clean
way of actually getting the face time
with them with them clients
demonstrating that you're a credible uh
taught me for example taught me through
that call
i'm gonna stop on the spot here and
talk through it so you get their mobile
you call them up yeah what are you
saying you're saying hey just spoke to
this candidate we're currently working
with them we just want to do a
professional reference like what what's
this
like
yeah i could run it with you now it's
hi um have i got three two such and such
yeah um we're currently working with
this candidate this candidate is a
individual that you previously employed
before we put them in front of our end
client we need to ensure that they're
professionally referenced
which demonstrates the caliber and the
quality of the agency that we are yeah
which is a quick mini selling to the
company
um we then will go through that
reference in detail um ensuring that the
candidate is of a good quality yeah but
then we're quickly flipping that
conversation and saying
well would you hire that candidate back
um okay and if they say yes
you're putting a brand new client with a
candidate that you've head-hunted which
you may or may not have a job for right
and you've made the fee which is great
if they're saying no we're not going to
hire that candidate back for me
i view that as a
a positive uh
like i think that's a positive pushback
sure um are you hiring at the moment
really easy question sure maybe they
don't want to hire that candidate back
but maybe they they're still hiring uh
and if they're hiring for me uh it's an
opportunity to pitch in our services
demonstrate the professional reference
calendar we speak um or if they're not
hiring uh
awesome technique which is start date
backwards um let's actually educate and
consult that client on why they should
be looking at that talent now maybe they
want to hire that candidate but they
don't have any open spots right but
maybe by the time that candidate resigns
works its notice period and speaks that
uh person we can align some dates
there's so many
and no is never a no in recruitment you
just need to be able to deal with that
objection handling yeah so it's
basically yeah okay no thanks for
sharing i know i put you on the spot but
that's just really useful for people
yeah and then just quickly on this
because i think this is interesting
like does it has a candidate giving you
permission to do this definitely
definitely we'll ask the candidate for
two professional references that they
need what's the why behind that i don't
know i don't feel like many recruiters
would do that like when you said to
canada we need two professional
references are they not going well glenn
like you need to trust me this is
my background this is my experience
who's gone through it what what's what's
the sort of strong why
uh behind them then going okay glenn i
understand that now
here are the two people that you can
speak to yeah so
if you create competition with that
candidate paul and you say to that
candidate look i'm not going to put you
forward unless you okay professionally
references
periods and i'm not going to disclose my
client until you give me the
professional references
they will give you the professional
references and if they don't they're not
going to get put forward to that client
that's the way our view is and
the other angle on there is um we want
to ensure that we're working with the
best caliber candidates and
their word is good enough we're engaging
with them we're proactively head hunting
them they're feeling special but you
need to be able to turn that
conversation on its head really quickly
and appreciate that although that
candidate is special because you've
head-hunted them they're passive they're
probably your clients competitors top
performer which your client is going to
pay an agency fee for
there's also hundreds of developers out
there in the market space and they're
one of
hundreds of developers that we're
engaging with every single day so
although they're
of the caliber we want to speak to we
want to ensure that we're uh levelling
ourselves up in that conversation to
ensure that they appreciate that they're
working with a really hot headhunter and
to work with a really good headhunter
they need to be sure that they're
passing our criteria as well okay
there's a give and take i i don't
when i'm speaking to a candidate i
haven't done this for a while but
i won't roll over there and go i'm just
a recruitment consultant
i want to turn that conversation around
and for them to appreciate that they
should feel
pretty grateful to have that
conversation with me
which creates a very different dynamic
to that to that engagement hey everyone
a real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast partners vincerie and
sauce breaker because you listen to this
podcast you are able to get your hands
on exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
so cool so i want to a couple couple of
things just to tie us over and i want to
talk about because i know you're really
passionate about you helping people get
up to speed and helping them progress
really quickly so just just two key
things here before we uh move on so i'd
love to ask you this question which is
if glenn was to start from everything
that you've learned
if glenn was to start a brand new market
tomorrow
that you've obviously done the market
mapping on you've identified
what what would you what would those
first 90 days look like what would you
what would be the game plan for those
first 19 days knowing everything that
you now know what you've learned if you
start to a brand new market from scratch
what would the the first 90 day game
plan be
the first thing i do is get myself in
the right mindset like mindset is
everything uh being complacent is just
not an option i'd be
reflecting on where i started i'd view
that as day one and
i'd be drawing on all my experience i'd
be building candidate and client pools
and i'd be using a business development
technique and really identifying that
really quickly about what bd technique
works and then i'd be building that
client i'd be building that market space
around that candidate uh through
different business development
techniques
with an objective where as soon as we're
in a position where we've got client
wins and we're producing revenue i'd be
looking at measuring that market space
and seeing what is the average uh what's
the average deal size um
what is the average uh
what's the average base salary how can i
increase that average terms of business
and really start sticking out from that
market space okay and then the other
thing i wanted to ask you thanks for
sharing that the other thing i wanted to
ask you was you mentioned headhunting
numerous times yeah obviously right now
this sort of for most people the market
that we're in there most people will say
i need more candidates right
what from your perspective what are the
principles of good headhunting yeah
um
i was having this conversation the other
day with the team which is pretty well
timed um
i think hard work
a lot of people will sit there and you
look at productivity across the day and
people
have just got to work harder and faster
and quicker you know if you put a glass
screen and you're sat there at desk and
you just
act like that you've got your
competition that sat there on the other
side of that glass screen who's quickest
that candidate who's quickest that uh
client um
and and for me
the fundamentals of head hunting is
pace urgency uh drive whilst you if
you're hiring an entry-level talent
they've got no experience of headhunting
and they've got no experience of uh
building uh a candidate pool so you've
got to be quite clear in terms of what
you want them to deliver and then in
terms of when when you're clear about
what the objectives are you want to be
driving pace urgency real volume through
there and then working with them to
critique that volume into quality and i
think
for me a good headhunter is uh is really
really focused on on volume and quality
um i think if you're just doing volume
you're going to miss the boat and you're
going to engage with a load of
candidates which just aren't off the
caliber that your client is going to
hire and i think if you're
if you're sat there and you're only
doing quality you're not going to have
the volume piece and yeah at 94 we look
at what high performance is and we
define that through
work rate and the quality and the
quality and i think you've just got to
have both what what's the what's the
objective of a headhunting call in your
opinion
to engage passive talent which would be
our clients
clients competitors top performers
and be moving them through a transition
piece of uh
activating that candidate exclusively
for us to be able to move them into to
our own climb
and like again i'm getting a bit
granular here just quickly because this
is helpful it's okay what so
what does like talk to me through like
if you're how if you're helping on your
team get better at head like those
because we're talking calls here right
yeah
you've got a candidate's mobile they're
a high performer you know that because
their skill set you've got that
experience
like
getting granular what are some of the
things that you're really trying to help
your team do really well on that call
that you think produces good results
tonality opening is it
me introducing myself on that call
important is it asking a good quality
open question like i don't know what any
granular stuff yeah um
the granular part of of that call um
like we do a lot of training investment
into people like
entry level no prior experience purely
organically run so a big part of my role
is training and development so i run all
of the training and development across
the technology team so when someone
starts in the business i'll sit down
with them and they get a really
full-on approach for their first month
of going through the fundamentals of
recruitment yeah and a big part of that
is being able to effectively head hunts
exactly and
when we're sat there and we're looking
at that candidate paul for me the head
hunting is
you being able to professionally
introduce yourself through that elevator
pitch
um and breaking that call down into two
i always break that call down into two
you want a peak interest you don't want
to say who the client is you want to you
want to remain anonymous until you've
built that fact-finding profile of that
candidate before you're even disclosing
who that that candidate who that client
is
and
you're getting the professional
references that that you need so you
want to be able to build a profile of
what that candidate looks like um
we use the acronym pi quite a lot
personal internal external let's build a
character profile of that candidate
so then we can effectively position an
opportunity which is going to
really excite them which isn't going to
be around comp it's not going to be
around
progression it's normally going to be
granular details around
have they got a wife have they got kids
do they need a better work life balance
how do they need flexibility it's it's
all in the detail when you're doing that
that call so thanks for sharing that
yeah so
last ten minutes here okay
so with
i want to just talk to you a bit about
the the leadership journey so i know
like i've said super passionate you've
said multiple times organically grown
our platform i know you're really
passionate about bringing young people
into your business and helping them be
successful
a lot of people want to do that yeah
some succeed some don't some people
um hire young talent then they're not in
recruitment anymore after three months
or whatever so talk me through your
philosophy when it becomes to aha glenn
the 19 year old tomorrow these are the
things that we're going to do with this
person that we believe is going to give
them the best possible chance of
progressing becoming our future managers
leaders
what sort of do you think's really
helped you enable your young talent and
your and your team and your business to
then become those managers and leaders
that you obviously want them to become
and also need them to become what sort
of philosophies and
approaches have really helped you
achieve that
yeah so i guess i'd break this down to a
few key areas so the first thing is
the
the hiring so you've got to hire the
very best people that you think are a
caliber which you're super comfortable
with with ensuring that they're going to
be successful and that's a two-way chat
you know are they comfortable they'll be
successful on our platform and are we
comfortable they'll be successful on
their platform
but for me then the next thing is uh
the uh i guess the the training uh well
the investment piece and i guess you
could you could break the investment
piece down into two key areas and for me
that would be training and development
and career growth so training and
development you know that's the external
training the internal training ensuring
that they're getting the right training
and development in order to actually be
successful on the platform and
once they've got the training and
development in place the second thing
for me around career growth is
is very much the progression opportunity
you know is there a clear structure for
them to actually progress through the
business so
you know when i look over that structure
it's
inside six months of being employed at
94 you can hire your first head count
wow you know inside your second year you
should be expected to lead anywhere
between two to two to four
maybe six heads yeah you're moving into
your third year you know i work with a
gent who was one of my first hires
called michael mooney um he spent his
first year actually train uh
billing being a good miller
and then over the last 18 months we've
built them up to a team of nine oh wow
really good um
so you can expect to be you know his
third year you know anywhere from
eight through to 12 heads i think it's a
good position and then in your fourth
year 20 plus heads you know i think
that's a really really good position to
be in um you know and if you're four
years in
and you're 19 and you you're 23 and
you're leading 20 plus heads i think
you're doing really well how how do you
how do you help because that's really
difficult how do you support how do you
approach supporting those people because
when i speak to people like that they're
some of the most stressed and overworked
people in the recruitment business
but they're also
the most crucial and important because
you're not going to be achieving your
scaling goals if you don't have people
like that that you can obviously hire
people underneath how do you make sure
they don't burn out how do you support
them professionally mentally what's been
your approach to that that's worked yeah
so like
professionally um i'm having
conversations with
all of the managers that i work with
directly around
what do you actually want to get out of
your life personally
to actually
and recruitment should enable that so
you're
having conversations about how do you
get a mortgage how do you buy property
um
don't get burnt out take a week off a
quarter and i think
it's moving into a leadership role it's
not about hard numbers all the time it's
not about
build your team up build your clients up
of course we want our
junior managers to do that and more
develop managers to do that but it's
more around
where do you want to take your life and
i think that's really important to
highlight um
you know i've i've got people that
i'm sat down i'm breaking down their
their earning profile and going cool you
can afford a house worth x and if you
keep running at this rate you should be
able to afford why and
and for me that that's super engaging
for me to be able to take someone on
that journey from entry level through to
you know leading a team of nine in three
years is
it's really rewarding to actually watch
so if i'm listening to this right now
and i want to hire more organic talent
completely green um
what what advice would you give to me to
sort of give me the best chance of
getting the best out of those people
um
i would say
get the right training
platform in place um
i'd say hire the best people invested
into them through training and ensuring
they've got good quality career growth
um ensure that they're individuals and
motivators um through through that model
um always be up skilling um
and ensure that your your talents always
looked after um
and and if you're doing that
they should progress really quickly on
our platform
individuals should earn super super well
on our platform and as a net result um
we retain that talent and we'll be able
to scale up and i actually think in the
market today um speaking to peers
organic
growth is the only way forward
to ensure that you can actually go
through the scalability that you want to
you
having a blend of experienced hires and
organic hiring just
for me i can't comprehend how that looks
and how that works
because i just don't think it's a way
that you can go through the scalability
that you want to yeah now what i take
from that is like as you said having
make sure the standards are kept high in
terms of who you're bringing in and i
don't know obviously knowing a bit more
about your guys business then really
commit to investing in those people
external trainers your own time
development and stuff like that is going
to be fundamental so talk as you come to
the end here then talk to me about
obviously
i said earlier that you've obviously
then grown it to 30 people obviously
have big goals obviously you've shared
some of the challenges early on right bd
not working thing and learning that the
hard way talk to me a bit about the
future then before we finish like what
are you excited by yeah what are the big
goals that you have for they'll see the
business that you've worked so hard to
build
yeah so
for me the objective is to
in partnership uh with ed to build this
business through to
circa 250 heads by 2025 which is our
midterm strat and delivering an ebit
position about five million pounds okay
um we want to be best in class at
software engineering cyber security tax
and legal um we want to be in a position
where at the moment we've got our london
office covering uk and europe and we're
also building incubated businesses that
is focused on the u.s new york market um
in the middle of 23 we're going to move
our
our
incubators out there full time into new
york into the office and set up there
double that business through
packing that round good quality graduate
hiring
run that business and then use that
business to then uh scale out our west
coast business as well by 2024. so we've
got a clear clear strategy on headcount
ebits um
growth by being best in class in the
markets that we're working in uh and a
clear plan on them office locations love
it
glenn i'm excited to see if that happens
we'll probably have to get you back on
when you're in the in the thick of
achieving these goals but been an
absolute pleasure thanks a lot for
coming on thanks very much for having me
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode